wall street journal editorial board
calling out nato in an op-ed the
headline ukraine can win with enough
help
an excerpt from that the public message
out of thursday's meeting of nato
leaders in brussels is sure to be heavy
on unity and resolve in support of
ukraine but the unfortunate reality is
that the democratic alliance confronting
vladimir putin still isn't doing enough
to ensure the russians defeat
a new fox poll finds 63 percent of
voters say they believe the united
states should be doing more to help
ukraine
that's a mix politically 63 percent of
anything is a lot
and there is strong bipartisan agreement
on that issue as i'm mentioning look at
that
general jack keane
is in focus retired four-star general
fox news senior strategic analyst and
chairman at the institute for the study
of war general thank you for being in
focus today
i i want to begin with
where where or how we begin to
lead rather than waiting to see what
putin's going to do kim weapons are
being talked about so we know we've got
cyber warfare going on
to fight as well i mean when do we how
do we take charge at this point what
should next steps look like
well we've been talking about the same
thing for weeks here
that it's certainly applaudable that
we're giving support to the ukrainians
but
we've been parsing our words about what
really is the mission here the mission
is
is really to help the ukrainians defeat
the russians and drive them out of the
country and there really is an
opportunity to do that
obviously the situation is stalemated at
the strategic level and ukrainians are
making some tactical gains let's get all
in to help them do that i mean obviously
the greatest deterrence
from russia ever attacking a nato
country is their defeat
in ukraine
and and the bite administration for some
reason
doesn't even want to use the word we
want to win
we want the ukrainians to win against
the russians and why do we keep wringing
our hands almost daily
about russian's possible use of wmd
chemical biological nuclear weapons and
cyber attacks
let's stop talking about that what we
should be doing is making
unequivocal strong statements united
states and nato when it comes to wmd
harris
it is unacceptable we will not let it
stand and we will take decisive action
against you and you will be responsible
for expanding the war so not the united
states and not nato that is what is
needed i'm looking to see if it comes
out of this nato g7 meeting but i
suspect it will not
so you just gave a red line that is
something we have not gotten from the
biden administration and when you talk
about the possibility the threat of
nuclear war a new fox poll shows
a large majority of voters are concerned
about not only russia's invasion of
ukraine
but also about the threat of both a
conventional and a nuclear war between
the united states and russia and today
this
from russia's deputy ambassador on nukes
if russia is provoked by nato if russia
is attacked by nato i don't know
so we are we are nuclear power
why not it's not the right thing to uh
to to threaten russia and to try to
interfere so
when you're dealing with the nuclear
power of course you have to calculate
all the possible outcomes of of your
behavior
the new york times reporting that the
white house has quietly assembled a team
of national security officials to sketch
out scenarios of what to do if russia
unleashes its most powerful weapons like
nukes chemical or biological the group
is dubbed team tiger and that team may
have its work cut out for it general a
stark warning
this morning from nato's chief we'll
watch together
we see the rhetoric
and we see that russia is trying to
create some kind of pretext accusing
ukraine united states nato allies for
preparing to use
chemical and biological weapons
as you're talking general i'm going to
ask my team to pop up that statistic
that that polling again so people can
see where americans are falling on this
and how worried they are
is that worry legitimate at this point
well
look you just heard the nato chief
there's the hand ringing again
no no positive statement about where we
stand on that he's just hand-wringing
and what the deputy
from russia was doing there is in trying
to intimidate us it's brinksmanship
they're trying to get inside our head i
think
the fear inside this white house is
palpable when it comes to
nuclear weapons but think through this
issue just a little bit
and we can have a conversation with the
american people about it as well there's
not a lot of leadership in talking about
it other than the hand-wringing i mean
if russia used nuclear weapons the loss
to them and the loss to europe and the
world writ large
is devastating there's no advantage for
them to do something like that but
listen we didn't deter putin from
invading because our policies were so
weak they showed up on the border 60
days after biden took the oath of office
and we
we delayed the shipment of arms that the
trump team had scheduled for that period
of time because we didn't want to
provoke them
we have always been taken a step back
and operating from a position of
weakness what i'm suggesting is the way
to deter the use of those weapons is
make certain that they know that we're
going to hold them accountable and they
absolutely will pay a price
for it that's that's what i'm seeking
here
not the handwringing that we keep seeing
going on and you just saw it uh from
the chief of nato who i have a lot of
respect for
wow what you said the fear is palpable
in the white house and if we see it we
know that the enemy sees it too
i want to get to this
this is where we are
with russia right now according to
pentagon spokesperson john kirby just a
bit ago on america's newsroom
we have tried uh on numerous occasions
to connect secretary austin with his
counterpart chairman milley the chairman
of the joint chiefs of staff has also
tried to connect with his counterpart
we've made multiple uh uh
multiple attempts here but they have not
they have not answered up they've
declined to take these calls
they're not taking our calls
general
not surprising i mean given the
performance of the of the russian
military and they're back on their heels
and as opposed to knocking down one city
after another which was their intent
they're digging in outside the capital
city which was the main effort russian
has gone to ground and they are
preparing defensive positions
against the ukrainians who would have
ever thought that was possible a month
ago certainly not the russian generals
and not most of us that's why they're
not taking the call they don't have much
to say
real quickly general it's got to be
quick if they use kim weapons
then
basically putin's saying he's willing to
hurt his own people because there's no
way to hit that urban area if that's his
you know disastrous plan without killing
some of his own troops i mean it would
be horrible and what if that cloud
reaches a nato nation i mean it could
happen
well yeah most definitely listen russian
troops
were in syria
at air bases and uh spread out on
multiple bases when assad was using
chemical weapons i don't think the
russians care one way or the other about
anything like that all they care about
in this case is their military
objectives and the political and
strategic objectives and that's that's
just the facts of it if they really
cared about their military they would
that unit would be taking care of their
dead and taking them off the battlefield
it would be sustained logistically with
food and water and supplies they don't
have systems and and a moral compass
even to take care of their own troops
properly so they would be somewhat
dismissive of the idea that russian
troops could hurt be hurt by the use of
a chemical weapon they fundamentally
don't have that kind of a moral
underpinning and
that
those are the facts that the russian
citizens need to hear of course he's
blocking all of that right now but those
people waiting for those soldiers to
come home those families of those
military men and women in the russian
force
that's the truth they need to hear
general jack keane always great to have
you your expertise your time thank you
yeah thank you harris i went on brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here
on youtube so subscribe right now